so earlier this week in a sales meeting
two of our guys had their biggest month
ever one made 107 107 000 the other one
made 72 thousand dollars the one that
made 107 great attitude upbeat future
looks bright the 72 was a little bit
down the 107 after they had their
biggest month ever he took his wife and
himself to a nice football game they
went to a nice vacation they had a great
time the 72 after having a
record-breaking month was back to
business as usual and it was kind of
down a little bit so this led to one the
best sales meeting we had in this year
and it brought out two issues with sales
people and business people that i want
to talk about here today so here's what
it is number one
72 he's having record-breaking months
after months after he's never made this
kind of money before ever he's never
made this kind of money before he makes
72 i ask him so how did you reward
yourself he says what do you mean i said
what did you do did you when you had
made this kind of money did you take
your wi-fi did you kids did you go do
something for yourself is this the most
savings it's the most savings i've ever
had i've never made this kind of money
so did you go to a dinner together no
did you go buy something for your wife
no did you do some nothing i said so if
you make this kind of money and this
kind of success and you don't reward
yourself your psyche
doesn't see the value of you working
hard the next time because what are you
doing this for i said so okay maybe
you're doing this long term because
you're trying to save up for a down
payment for a house
or you're trying to save up for it says
no nothing i just i'm just working to
make money i said if you go with that
approach here's what's going to happen
to your income it's going to go back
down you have there has to be a reward
to it when you're making this kind of
money if you don't your enthusiasm will
go away you got to take your wife out to
dinner 400 dinner did you guys do that
no take your kids out to a nice little
park have a good time with them all day
did you do that no go get yourself
something nice maybe a nice watch maybe
a nice suit nice something that you like
is there anything you want yes have you
done that no i'm not telling you to go
buy 25 000 rolex because you haven't
made that kind of money i'm not telling
you to go buy ferrari i'm not telling
you go buy an r8 i'm telling you to go
do something to reward yourself so
that's one of the mistakes by the way
that mistake is about five to ten
percent of salespeople that make this
mistake after they're winning for me
when i was coming up in sales i was from
this mindset work work work work then
one guy said you got to add some rewards
because if you don't have new rewards
and you replace them every time you're
going to hit a plateau so i'm coming up
i said if i get to six figures and i got
some money in the bank i'm going to go
to new york and i'm 23 years old at the
time i'm going to stay at the hotel i
want to watch a ball drop and i want to
spend three thousand dollars at sacs
boom i hit that number by 24 25 i go to
new york i stayed at the hotel i watched
the ball drop i celebrated new year's
eve with two of my friends one two sack
shop i remember the purple shirt i got i
remember exactly what i bought came back
the next one if i have a hundred
thousand dollars in the back i'm buying
an at 600. i did if i have a quarter
million dollars an event i'm buying an
escalade and a harley i did everything
was tied i just bought a nice
boat a yacht and i just bought a nice
ferrari uh sf90 both of them are seven
figure uh toys but they're both tied to
net worth and savings because that's the
reward and punishment but let me give
you the other person with a side which
is 90 of people in sales and business
when i'm coming up and i'm 22 23 24
we're in the sales office together
obviously got a group of people we go in
there monday morning and we say guys
here's what i want us to do this week
what's that let's put a number that if
we hit it saturday night we go have the
time of our lives
let's put a number that if we hit it
sunday we're going to go watch a laker
game let's put a number if we hit it
we're going to go to xyz so everyone
said yeah yeah yeah let's do that let's
do that five sales ten sales whatever
the number is we'd put it up there then
saturday night would come a couple of
the guys who didn't hit their goals
they'd be at the office like i didn't
hit my goal you know it's like okay
great the other guys who hit their goal
great let's go out there was always one
or two of the guys whether they hit the
goal or not they wanted to still go
party
whether they hit the numbers or not they
still went and parted do you know what
happened to every one of those guys that
would
reward themselves whether they hit the
numbers or not none of them made it past
two three years in a business
because psychologically your standards
are low you're so easy on yourself and
so you're like well i deserve it you
don't even know i worked i tried i tried
my best yeah in the nba if you try your
best and you don't want a championship
they don't give you a championship ring
just because you tried your best in the
world of business just because you tried
your best that doesn't mean you end up
building a nice big business that helps
you become financially free and your
dreams become a reality you have to hit
numbers and you got to perform so
if you're watching this
there's a very high likelihood if you're
in business and sales you're either in
this category of this category but odds
are 90 percent
95 on this category because their
standards are too low take inventory of
yourself and ask yourself one
you know i plateaued
i was killing it but i've plateaued
do you have three new goals that you
have to hit no maybe you need to come up
with new three goals that excites you
put a number to it go hit them and have
your goal whatever that thing is to
reward yourself on the other side are
you somebody that you don't even do
goals because whether you hit them or
now you're going to reward yourself
saturday and sunday anyways maybe you
got to get a little bit tougher on
yourself a quote that made me look at
business in a completely different way
was the following quote it said the
harder you are on yourself the easier
life will be on you let me say that one
more time the harder you are on yourself
the easier life will be on you now
some some youtube philosophers will tell
you the complete opposite be easy on
yourself life is tough
don't be so tough on yourself life is so
tough right yeah you're right i'm just a
little too tough on myself you choose
whichever philosophy you want to buy
into i can tell you 20 something years
ago which philosophy i bought into and i
know it's an annoying philosophy to say
the tougher you are on yourself life is
easier on you but it's just the truth
uh uh you know and i'm not talking about
critical i'm such a loser i'm such an
idiot i'm so i'm not talking about that
i'm talking about i think you can do
more
i think you can push harder i think you
can make 30 more calls i think you can
run five more appointments i think you
can do more next week to hit that goal i
think you need to do better to get that
goal that you want to get yourself i'm
talking about that not critical not name
calling not down you know none of that
stuff it's about a little bit tougher
about the expectations being higher of
what you can do performance wise in
order to reward yourself
having said that if you enjoyed the
video give us a thumbs up and subscribe
to the channel i got another video i
want you to watch it's 10 enemies of
success if you've never seen this video
before 10 enemies of success you may
want to click and watch this here take
care everybody bye
[Music]
you